[Musique]
je ne sais pas quoi vous emmener au
poste
on va lui parler vous pouvez pas lui
parler avant françois raimond vi a
besoin de manger sélectionneur
ils ont été réglés
oubliez tout le temps madame vous
pourrez lui passer un coup de fil dès
qu'on sera arrêté mes posts mais que sa
voiture
mais m
mais ta lomagne
[Musique]
de profil
bon remettez-vous de face maintenant on
a besoin de voir romain montrélais
[Musique]
lever la tête s'il vous plaît
on doit voir votre cou
retirez votre chemise et donner la mc
auley
je suis
et m
bonjour madame cannetti je suis le
lieutenant dan mireuil voici le
lieutenant harry en bronze
on aimerait vous poser quelques
questions votre lieu de résidence et à
dorchester c'est exact depuis quand êtes
vous mariée ça fait environ trois ans
vous avez de la famille dans la région
des parents il s'en mord tweet est ce
que vous pouvez me dire ce qui va
m'arriver
et bien dès que nous aurons fini nous
vous emmènerons à la prison de kingston
pour la mise sous écrou vous y serez
détenu jusqu'à l'audience préliminaire
c'est là que votre avocat et vous
pourrez plaidé devant je ne veux pas tu
avocate l'étape vous nommer un avocat
commis d'office
j'essaie un avocat pourrait vous
permettre sans doute de réduire votre
peine même s'il vous plaît du coupable
je veux pas d'avocat excusez moi je suis
déjà passé aux aveux
ces thèmes en prison
savez le plus fou dans cette histoire
c'est ma fille m'a appelée elle connaît
korat année dit elle a dit qu'elle n'a
rien d'une meurtrière que c'est une mère
sympathique elle fait du bénévolat
alors qu'est ce qui lui a pris de faire
ça elle est sous traitement quoi elle
n'a pas d'antécédents de problèmes
mentaux et prend parfois des cachets
pour dormir mais c'est tout le test de
drogue est négatif danemark on a toutes
les réponses sauf le mobile mais est ce
qu'on en a besoin on à ces aveux et on a
aussi 20 témoins oculaires fatale tu
sais bien tu sais bien quand une femme
tue quelqu'un c'est parce qu'ils ont ils
ont un lien intime ou oui je sais c'est
profile seulement
regarde là elle l'a pas ce profil
donc tu crois qu'elle manque en fait le
connaissait non je parle d'un point de
vue global hawk est cette femme a
agressé sa victime en public et avec son
couteau
elle lui a infligé de multiples
blessures il s'agit d'un meurtre
impulsif c'est émotionnel c'est pour ça
que ça n'a aucun sens elle a peut être
tout simplement craqué parfois les gens
intériorise tout et puis quelque chose
leur fait péter les plombs et un pauvre
type en fait les frais écoute harris je
comprends ce que tu veux dire je
t'assure mais comment les faits
pourrait-il mentir
et pour mon mari
j'attends depuis des heures personne je
suis navré c'est trop tard conduit à la
prison
non
est ce que ça vous deviez me prévenir
quand il viendrait vous voulez mais
promis il n'est jamais venu
il n'a pas appelé désolée
[Musique]
m